[Musique]
un fond intox avec Julie Chouteau
bonjour Julie vous nous emmener
aujourd'hui au Philippines ou la
campagne présidentielle est lancée une
campagne marquée justement par la
désinformation exactement alors ce qu'il
faut rappeler déjà c'est que cette
campagne est un peu particulière un
Raphaël puisque le favori à cette
présidentielle c'est lui il s'agit de
Ferdinand Marcos junior qui n'est autre
que le fils de l'ancien dictateur oui
sanguinaire du même nom qui avait fait
régner la terreur quand même sur les
Philippines pendant 20 ans de 1965 à
1986 mais malgré cela et bien les
sondages prédisent une large victoire le
9 mai à l'héritier de ce clan Marcos
notamment grâce à son alliance avec un
autre clan très puissant celui du très
populaire Rodrigo duter donc l'actuel
président philippin connu notamment pour
sa lutte violente contre la droguée
Robert Drago du Tertre qui ne peut pas
se présenter mais sa fille était
pressent pour prendre sa suite à sa
fille la voici elle s'est finalement
rangée du coup derrière Ferdinand Marco
junior plus connu son surnom de bonbons
on a donc à faire à une alliance de deux
héritiers de deux clans puissants prêts
à tout pour le pouvoir y compris vous
l'avez dit à mener des campagnes de
désinformation sur les réseaux sociaux
des méthodes qui en fait ne sont pas
nouvelles aux Philippines qui en a fait
si j'ose dire sa spécialité en 2016 lors
de son élection le camp du terti avait
déjà inondé le web de fake news
notamment grâce à ses usines atrols vous
le savez ce sont ces personnes qui sont
payées pour relayer de inonder même le
web de fake news et se jouer des
algorithmes du terti avait même lui-même
admis avoir payé des gens pour le
défendre sur le réseau sociaux une
stratégie de communication et de
propagande de nouvelles générations si
on peut dire qui est particulièrement
efficace aux Philippines puisque les
Philippins passent en moyenne 10 heures
par jour sur Internet c'est un record
mondial en personne au monde ne tient ne
pas autant sur internet que les
Philippins en 2016 le rôle des réseaux
sociaux avait été si important que la
directrice de l'époque à la directrice
des relations publiques de Facebook
avait même qualifié la Filippi les
Philippines de patient 0 de l'épidémie
mondiale de désinformation la recette a
fonctionné en 2016 on peut supposer
qu'elle sera à nouveau employée pour la
présidentielle de cette année en fait
c'est déjà le cas un Raphaël puisque
défunt janvier Twitter a suspendu pas
moins de 300 comptes liés au clan Marcos
des contes supprimés pour avoir enfin
les règles en termes de manipulation et
de spam leur but blanchir le sombre
héritage politique des Marcos une
réécriture de l'histoire à qui s'adresse
notamment aux plus jeunes à aux
Philippins qui n'ont pas connu la
dictature sur la répression de marcosper
je vous le rappelle des milliers je
finis par avait perdu la vie et presque
35000 avaient été torturé les époux
Marcos inferdinand et sa femme Imelda
inconnue pour son train de vie fastueux
ont été paires de chaussures oui et de
robes
incroyables et donc le couple Marcos a
été classé tout de même par l'OMG
transper ici internationale deuxième
couple le plus corrompu de l'histoire et
aujourd'hui le fils du dictateur donc
Bang Bang le le favori à la
présidentielle et lui aussi accusé de
fraude fiscal mais sur internet de
nombreuses fake news comme celle-ci un
tentent de le discuter par exemple ce
message tourne beaucoup parmi ses
soutiens et il présente ce document qui
montrerait que bonbon est en règle avec
le fiscain sauf que il s'agit en fait
d'un récipissé à propos d'une location
d'un bail immobilier c'est-à-dire un
document qui n'a rien à voir avec ses
arrières fiscaux cette fausse
information a été divulguée débusqué par
l'excellent site rappeler c'est ce site
qui est dirigé par le prix Nobel de la
paix en fait de cette année enfin de
l'année 2021 Maria RSA Replay qui pointe
du doigt beaucoup d'autres fake news de
ce genre qui profite au clan Marcos
d'Outer RTL je vous invite à aller y
faire un tour si le sujet vous intéresse
on peut aussi citer le site philippin de
fact checking
verifies et d'ailleurs si on y fait un
tour on voit on y voit que de nombreuses
campagnes de désinformation ont pour
cible
Lenny Robredo c'est l'actuel
vice-présidente des Philippines qui
elles aussi est candidate à la
présidentielle et qui est l'ennemi juré
du clan Marcos du Tertre et aux
Philippines c'est fait que nous sont
presque toujours propagés par le même
mécanisme oui c'est ce que démontre ce
rapport de l'université britannique de
leads en fait un chargé vous voyez tout
en haut de l'échelle un chargé de
communication ou un publicitaire et
payer pour définir la stratégie puis les
influenceurs un des personnalités ou
autre partage des postes qui sont
ensuite repris par des internautes
lambda qui eux sont payés sont souvent
d'origine modeste et tout en bas de
l'échelle il y a des internautes
bénévoles des soutiens du candidat qui
diffusent massivement ces forces
d'informations jusqu'à les rendre
virales en tout cas c'est c'est
campagnes de désinformation sont devenus
vraiment un enjeu de la campagne à tel
point que hier le maire de la capitale
manie Isco Moreno qui est lui aussi un
candidat à la présidentielle a demandé
explicitement à ses partisans de ne pas
se livrer à tel de tel manœuvre de
telles campagnes de désinformation et de
s'en tenir au fait avéré merci Julie
c'était un faux int